there's been a major development in the
investigation into the murder of a
father who was killed while camping with
his two young daughters in California
last June
Anthony rato was charged yesterday with
one count of murder he also faces 10
counts of attempted murder in five
counts of burglary over string of
shootings that date back to 2016 Jamie
yuccas is at Malibu Creek State Park in
Calabasas California where the father
was murdered Jamie good morning to you
good morning officials temporarily
closed this very popular campground back
in June when Tristan Baudette was shot
in the head as he leaved
lay sleeping with his two young
daughters in a tent the suspect has a
lengthy criminal background including
illegal weapons possession and
apparently picked his victims at random
Anthony righta was blocked from cameras
by his public defender as he appeared in
a Los Angeles courtroom Monday he was
also in court back in November on
burglary and parole violation charges at
that time his unruly behavior led
authorities to shackle him to a chair
while wearing a spit mask authorities
reportedly say the 42 year old was a
survivalist who lived off stolen food
while often sleeping outside in the
Malibu area he now faces multiple
charges including the murder of 35 year
old Tristan Baudette sheriff's deputies
responded to a 911 call where they found
an adult male subject suffering from a
gunshot wound Baudette was gunned down
last june in the tent he was sharing
with his 2 and 4 year old daughters they
were not injured but are listed as
victims of attempted murder in the
felony complaint in the days after the
killing more victims came forward after
authorities revealed that several other
shootings had occurred in the areas
where it happened in June James Rodgers
told us he was shot in the arm while
sleeping in a hammock in the park I kind
of assumed they were aiming for my head
to be honest
because I sleep with my arm up meliss to
tangelo is also one of the victims named
in the complaint against rao de my
boyfriend walked around he was like
that's a bullet hole and I was like okay
it is right authorities released this
photo when they arrested righta in
october after spotting him on a ridge
top carrying a rifle in his backpack he
was suspected in a string of armed
burglaries sources tell Los Angeles
station KCBS that righta was positively
identified in security videos while
committing those crimes and they say
ballistics linked routers gun to
vedettes murder as well as to at least
five other shootings in the area in
court monday routers bail was set at 1.1
million dollars he did not enter a plea
and he is expected to be back in court
on later this month
Norah all right Jamie thank you so much